welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel's one division just
dropped an official teaser for its
season coming later this year on disney
plus
i'm in the process of breaking it down
frame by frame there is so
much that you can easily miss on this
trail if you're not watching closely but
yes as we've explained in other videos
of maximov truly has the power to reset
reality something that the marvel
cinematic universe hasn't really
explored a whole lot and
in this show it looks like it's going to
manifest in form of switching the
channel throughout old tv sitcoms again
stay tuned the next video on the channel
is going to dig into this frame by frame
let's quickly explain when this will
drop on the platform and what this
imagery seems to be telling us about
the plot of this and how it's going to
set up marble phase 4 going forward
now looking at the disney plus release
schedule the mandalorian season 2 is
premiering friday october 30th with its
eight episodes presumably releasing
weekly on fridays throughout november
and december
making the next open friday on disney
plus friday december 25th so that means
halloween with baby yoda
and christmas day with the ghost of
vision past
of course disney plus could release
monovision episodes at the same time as
new episodes of the mandalorian it's a
streaming app it can handle the
bandwidth or one of vision episodes
could drop on different days of the week
or mando episodes could release a few
episodes at a time or on different days
of the week as well but despite some
reporting that black widow might be
delayed to next year
and no official update about the falcon
of the winter soldier despite reshoots
that we've been seeing scraps of
this news directly from disney is
confirmation that there will
be some marvel content in the 2020
calendar year
and the fact that the first official
story of phase four might be
one division tells us a lot about how
important these episodes are gonna be to
marvel's future
and yeah i'm gonna do this a bit in
other videos but here we gotta focus
completely on one division everything we
know and really
explore a rumored element to the series
that i have not yet really discussed at
length but
looks increasingly likely to be central
to the premise
the dark hold look i gotta be honest the
whole concept of reading paper books has
become pretty unfamiliar to me
i guess the only paper i touch are like
these you know grocery store receipts
that i forgot were in my pocket but it
turns out this paper is actually pretty
valuable
because now you can get rewards by
scanning these thanks to
fetch rewards and thanks to fetch for
sponsoring this video so
fetch rewards offers users free rewards
on groceries just by scanning their
grocery receipts the whole process is
super easy and only takes seconds you
just scan your receipts you don't have
to worry about where the receipt is from
or what is on it
just scan the receipts and get points
you then redeem points and spend a
reward all from your mobile device in a
matter of minutes
you can even sync your fetch rewards
account with your amazon account and get
points for online purchases
you can use the points to earn to buy
gift cards from itunes amazon
gamestop target or my favorite chipotle
you better believe that any app that
gets me a free burrito bowl is gonna be
a favorite once you sign up for fetch
you can earn
even more bonus points by referring
friends and family to the app and now
through september 22nd there is a
limited time bonus of 7
000 points for every two friends you
refer check the app for details
the app is easy to use it's easy to sign
up easy to scan the receipts and easy to
save
use the link in this video's description
to sign up for fetch rewards
the easiest way to save money on
groceries use the promo code
new rockstars scan your first receipt
and get 2
000 points on your groceries so when it
comes to the one division plot
trailer footage shows wanda blinking in
and out of various sitcom realities with
a resurrected
vision in some of those realities she
appears to have twin children
believed to be the mutants billy kaplan
wiccan and tommy shepard's speed
we know that darcy lewis jimmy wu and an
adult monica rambo played by tiana paris
will join this cast and that this plot
will tie somehow into doctor strange's
multiverse madness catherine hahn will
join the cast as a quote
nosy neighbor which many of us believe
to be code for
agatha harkness a witch connected to one
of maximoff in the comics we'll go into
that more in a bit
there were some other reports over the
summer saying that evan peters who
played quicksilver in the fox x-men
universe
will join the cast as well maybe as an
alternate reality quicksilver or maybe
as i've suggested
methysto also last spring there were
some rumors
going around that the darkhold was gonna
be playing a fundamental role in the
wanavision story which isn't something
you really need these scoopers to report
because that's kind of an obvious go-to
move for any
wanda maximoff story see the darkhold is
marvel's book of sins or book of spells
it's constructed from dark matter from
the hell dimension written by the elder
god
chathan whose essence is actually buried
within wanda
he marked her at birth and it's his
presence that
allows her to use her chaos magic now
the dark hold has showed up another
marvel adjacent properties like agents
of shield related to the whole ghost
writer storyline
they suggested that red skull and nick
fury had been searching for it also in
marvel's runaways with the character
nico minoru whose mother tina minoru
technically appeared as a sorcerer
master of the hong kong sanctum
in the official canon mcu the first
doctor strange movie but it's pretty
clear that those other dark hold related
subplots from aegis of shield and
runaways are probably not
official mcu canon that's not coming for
me it's coming from kevin feige take it
up with him
it is believed that the dark hold might
have been one of the books of the
comartage library in doctor strange
and yes there's a very good chance that
it's going to be important in stew going
forward because
it was the dark hole that was used in
marvel comics to create the first
vampire and to create werewolves in the
world
we know blade is on his way to the mcu
so yeah the dark hole's on its way too
so here's what i think we're looking at
for the dark hole in one division wanda
maximoff
still grieving over the loss of her love
vision finds companionship with her
neighbor
agatha but you know as friendly
neighbors often are in the mcu
deceitful double agents agave will
actually secretly be a servant of a
higher power or a
lower power the gamble from agatha wanda
receives this
mystery spell book the darkhold written
in this unreadable dead language that
wanda somehow can understand thanks
inner demon
and so wanda uses this dark hole to
attempt to resurrect her lover
vision despite the fact that you know
he's an android and i doubt he has a
soul or dreams of electric sheep
but during this process wanda's mind
becomes linked with the tv
on in the background that's playing
classic sitcoms that wanda
ends up astral projecting herself into
leave it to beaver
bewitched full house roseanne
interestingly
all sitcoms that broadcasted originally
on abc and therefore intellectual
property of the disney media empire that
a marvel disney plus series should have
no legal issues blipping
into the vision that she envisions turns
out to be
an illusory trick by agatha's true
master
mephisto played by evan peters the
children that she envisioned having
mere soul puppets operated by mephisto
and as they are in the marvel comics
reabsorbed into mephisto
a conspiracy that agatha has been
manipulating wanda's mind
trying to erase from her mind but this
process ends up sending wonder maxum up
into a
thrilling psionic breakdown that resets
reality
leading us into a house of m adaptation
and i think this will set up the scarlet
witch as the misunderstood villain
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and it will be
wanda's fractured mind as i pitched in a
recent video that only the sorcerer
supreme bound to his hippocratic oath in
a portal kicking multiverse hopper
america chavez who lost her loved ones
to the cosmos as well
a mind that only this duo can save
discuss these marvel theories with me on
new rockstar's official discord server
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
and hit the notification bell so that
you're getting all of our videos the
moment they come out follow me on
instagram
ea boss follow new rockstars and thank
you for watching
[Music]
you